all right he's on his way up okay we
ready
what do you want us to do why do i have
to explain everything because we're
usually not on the same page
[Applause]
oh okay
and to you
[Applause]
stay away from aaron hey i'm your boss
why don't you
uh stay away from me i'm gonna stand
where i want okay you don't want to get
on my bad side
i've seen some horrible things i own
over 200 horror movies okay that's so
weird
just go away no you go away
[Music]
so andy what improvements would you make
as office manager for starters i really
think we can streamline communication
around here
that's a very heavy accusation to level
against toby
in charge of human resources that would
include communication
i think that toby's done a fine job
right i
i really wasn't trying to insult at any
anyone
i didn't think you were i have two
relationships with anthony
i have a personal relationship and i
have a professional relationship
personally yeah i think he's a rat and i
think he's responsible for the demise of
my relationship with aaron
professionally he broke up the happiest
couple in this
office how many windows are there in new
york city what
critical thinking common on-the-spot
question asked in an interview
okay uh let me think are you counting
car windows no how far away is the sun
uh 93 million miles
is it yeah and the diameter of the sun
is 870 000 miles which makes it 109
times wider than the earth
and 333 thousand times heavier than the
earth shut up about the sun
shut up about the sun
walk away [ __ ] well i managed my
department and i've been doing that for
several years now
and god i've learned a lot of life
lessons along the way
your department's just you right yes jim
but i am not easy to manage
great um can we just
we just have a lot of serious candidates
to get through today
so am i not a serious candidate
what do you want me to say i mean
there's a line of qualified people out
there we have a video cv from england
are we all just gonna pretend to okay
um what are your weaknesses
i don't have any ass
okay i need to talk to you you can't be
in here this is a lady's banner
aaron aaron i respect your privacy but i
will follow you in here every time you
go if that's what it takes
agreed not cool man
i really think you should leave someday
you are going to tell our grandchildren
about how their grandfather won you back
in a women's room can we talk about this
later i have to go
okay just read the letter under your
windshield wiper okay it explains
everything okay okay
one okay well
gotta catch a plane oh hey gabe i'm
sorry we we didn't get you a cake or
anything we're gonna miss you oh well
i'm still the corporately islanded
branch
you are not leaving not giving me a hug
okay you know what you don't need to
make that sound i'm sorry you were just
a lot bonier than i thought you were
gonna be
there were plenty of people who loved
touching me i'm a terrific hugger
i've been with a bunch of girls where
that's basically all they want to do
in case you can't read my my poker face
we will be reviewing our sales policies
i have 10 seconds to explain them or
this whole place blows up
magruva has anyone started calling you
gabe wod yet
not here
hey i need you to get the paperwork
rolling on a new workplace relationship
for you yes your game who are you seeing
that's
whom i am seeing is val from down in the
warehouse
i'm not technically seeing her but uh
i've seen her
with the eyes and uh there was
attraction in at least one direction
so you know i don't have to do paperwork
unless you're actually dating
okay well once this starts it's going to
be moving fast it's going to be hot and
heavy
and i don't want a bunch of bureaucratic
red tape wrapped around my jock you know
but i mean have you talked to her yeah
we had a whole conversation about
mondays
do you know her last name yeah tubby i'm
going to tell you her last name tomorrow
because she's going to be screaming it
tonight she's going to be screaming her
own last name
hey watch it
good luck gabe gabe did aaron ever tell
you that she loves you
no no no no no no no no no no
she wouldn't even let me say it it was
adorable she'd plug her ears and scream
her heart out
can you stop talking because every word
out of your mouth is like the squawk of
an ugly pelican
i got a tattoo for you i didn't ask you
to get that nike swoosh nobody did you
did that for you
just do it you were the it
that i was just doing uh you play oh i
like to create soundscapes
imagine one instant of a song expanded
to be the size of the universe
i can't even do that this one's called
earthrise on the moon
[Music]
that's so beautiful what kind of music
are you into peter
uh i like all kinds of music gabe really
all kinds do you like songs of hate
written by the white knights of the ku
klux klan
are you even hearing this maybe he
didn't even say that he's not a very
sophisticated man i mean he can't use
chopsticks so
do i need to say anything else aaron
i've
been to japan i know how to use
chopsticks
so well come back
one night give me one night what is that
supposed to be everything
my doubts are blasted
i wish they had a chart for how much
protein powder to scoop for a 180 pound
man with no fat
protein powder huh you cut it with water
why don't you just take estrogen
there you go boys see how papa takes
care of you
[Laughter]
i remember when people thought biceps
were all that
they'd flex them all night at the disco
attack oh i bet you think it's all about
core huh yeah core is critical
there are four tenants of pilates that i
live my life by
one lanthan two elongate
listen guys i think we all want to know
the same thing right who's the strongest
well there's only one way to solve that
thigh curl contest all right here we go
everybody
may the manliest man win go
feast on this louis i love the bird
furnace where i live come on gabe you
can't handle his hamstrings you're
getting hypno thighs
speed
quick phone call from you guys keep
going eight
nine hello ken we got it
very funny jim yeah jim way to mock us
for perfecting our bodies
everyone conference room now
all right did someone say girl talk
sometimes i wonder if i have ovaries in
my scrotum
because i am great at girl talk have you
guys been watching any good korean soap
operas
i'm pretty deep into he junk cinderella
girl although i definitely fast forward
through the young tay storylines
do you think i'd like that or is it
important to have an asian fetish
uh i think you're gonna need to have an
asian fetish yeah
it'll be upsetting if you don't everyone
please
relax i think you're gonna like this
surprise guest
happy birthday to cave oh get out
skeleton man
very funny everyone who wrote captions
under my doodle
i'm not even kidding they're pretty good
which one in particular
yeah which one well the first one has a
surprise factor
i'm a suck sucks suckity saber booyah
no no no no no but uh i suppose the
second one is the better written line
you suppose what's to say i'm supposed
to be wearing red gloves
but my color cartridge portal got jammed
again okay
gloves one for you cool thanks
and one for you oh thanks oh you missed
your head
there you go go stick fast
you